okay two and a half half for
magnus carson who saved himself
uh just
just twice won by winning i mean the
second one was really i mean like the
third game was really really
completely lost um
so eduardo creating problems for
the world champion but of course
the score is very much in favor
of magnus now queen d7
which i mean it shows that black black
wants to play b6 bishop b7
b1 b6 d3
bishop b7 then you probably have many
plans you can go with 697 you can go 94
it's a close position so there's a lot
of rooms to do
to do a bit uh what you want knight h6
is interesting
he wants to go here and here you can
always go e4 but it's risky
it's risky to wait for also some ideas
to to go like this to take
and yeah maybe with the knight here
actually
you can always even give sometimes and
pretend that
uh the long diagonal a1 h8 is closed
and you go knight f6 and it's it's
possible
but magnus chose a completely
different plan with f5
then testing he wants to take with the
knight here
okay okay one
yeah no of course it's obvious that
magnus is playing a bit of random
openings
as black at least as white is playing e4
and also limo
which is not really a sideline
now you put something on d4 it's what
they do
in such positions i don't know what you
exactly
do as as why
as black as white soy okay now i have
some tricks here
like dc
um 94 knight c5
knight c5 is working apparently again
yes it's working again
some chipo knight c5 he will spot it
eduardo
he's a good tactician come on
either he will sit
not you see here i told you sometimes
magnus needs some
some time to warm up busy day in
pamplona i guess
many many official
uh stuff to do so
yeah i'm not surprised the knight c5
came
if bishop f3 tomato it's what maybe
magnus missed bishop d1
i can i can do whatever i can do that
this is just
an exchange up okay you take back the
exchange actually
i go here you go knight c3 and i go
somewhere with a bishop i don't know
something like that and it's just to
pull up two bishops
should be winning for for black and this
is a bad blunder because now what do you
do
so uh i don't know
but he will find a chance he will fight
this is don't worry
this is a hundred percent that magnus
will find a way to continue the game to
create some troubles
ask questions i don't know which one
but he will fine i mean this is no
worries
zero worries about that
bishop f3 played so knight d7
bishop d1 will be played because you
have to take back the queen
as always the queen would might be a bit
too much
and now you have this option to take or
to take
if you take here you attack both hooks
which is a good news
knight e2 king h2 knight c3 and you can
just move the bishop somewhere
and still attack that's
one of the possible continuations he
took on the f8 immediately
so knowing magnus he will take withokya
and now 92 knight c3 and he will try to
save that
end game which is of course completely
lost
no king f1 of course king f1 was a way
to go wrong
because knight g3 is in here but even
even that is good for for
for white actually but you don't want to
to allow such
so knight c3 and now move the bishop
bishop d2 yeah this is the reason the
ball takes stakes
and to be shops
will this be enough
bishop p1 protecting here bishop c5 a4
good technique so far
there's some kind of blockade on dark
square
again white is winning
black is uh struggling but
i don't expect eduardo to win that game
actually
to be fully honest with you
let me show before good move king g2
will come maybe h4 h5
trying to weaken the spawns
so it is very difficult to imagine how
how
how we get tricked but 92 is a good
start
you can play a four and then you get
this
opposite color ending which should be
winning
but already you know suppose it's called
bishops
and you play f3 wow so solid
okay king g7 kg2
at least it's very easy to play with
white
okay g5 bishop d5 wants to enter at some
point
maybe d4 is a big big threat
okay bishop d6 d4
and then
it's a disaster
that's a complete disaster
but yeah how to improve it's not
completely obvious to me
um this something like
to try to orange h4
[Music]
because if you go a5 doesn't bring
anything okay okay six
um what for absolutely
no clue yes ten seconds
king f6 check no not all
ah okay play something b1 a5
okay now e6 will come in okay five no
no no no this is not good
h5 okay it's trying to find some play
e6 what's wrong with e6 rg for
intermediate okay this is beautiful
g4 what do you go with orc bishop b4 and
now you are oh
completely paralyzed that's black
that's what would be difficult to save
actually
takes take c5 i guess he's coming no
how to finish the game one more time it
will be difficult
we know it we all know it c6 attacking
the pawns e5
is not a beautiful move but you have
what it takes to to protect
bishop f5 and this is not it doesn't
work he wants to check this is a good
move
okay he wants to collect on g5 this is a
good idea
but okay fate oh so successful oh he's
taking on the fate come on
eduardo you can't take on f8 here
i mean come on
no no no no no it's a total
okay we want some something exciting
no
okay it's a total low now you can never
okay maybe oh yeah bishop to e3 and it's
a blockade
bishop to f4 nietzsche
tablas
tablastablas amigo and three one for
magnus
in game two three four